A Christmas Carol adaptations range from the
delightful to the derivative.
Just how do the many iterations of Dickens'
classic tale of redemption stack up?
From the total disasters to the heartfelt
classics...
"Humbug."
...here are A Christmas Carol adaptations
ranked from worst to best.
Have you ever thought to yourself that A Christmas
Carol could use some slapstick animal gags
to undercut all the Victorian gloom?
How about a sleeker, younger Ebenezer Scrooge
who's given a second chance at love?
Perhaps a love song performed by Kate Winslet?
No?
Well, that's too bad, because 2001's Christmas
Carol: The Movie is stuffing all that and
more into 81 minutes of tooth-gritted cheer.
It's not just that stuff that makes this take
on Dickens so skippable.
Despite the A-list talent, Christmas Carol:
The Movie is remarkably lifeless.
The facial animation doesn't ever look quite
right, the acting is, at best, stiff, and
the entire operation feels dumbed down.
This adaptation's fatal flaw is that it doesn't
trust Dickens, and it doesn't trust its audience.
This 2003 TV movie attempts to liven up the
classic tale by replacing Scrooge with a selfish
talk show host and moving the story from Victorian
London to modern-day Hollywood.
It's an intriguing idea on its own.
What setting better represents a story of
greed, empathy, and false fronts than Hollywood?
And hey, isn't the idea of Scrooge as an image-obsessed
celebrity pretty great?
In concept, it's all strong and innovative.
Too bad the execution isn't.
A Carol Christmas is little more than a fresh
coat of paint that flakes away over the course
of the movie, revealing that it wasn't all
that necessary to begin with.
The modern setting makes Dickens' story more
cloying than anything else.
Removed from sooty London, the sickly children
and terrifying visions of the future feel
more like after-school specials than grave
warnings.
Worst of all, A Carol Christmas is simply
boring.
By the end the audience isn't so much watching
the movie as it is waiting it out.
The cranky celebrity might learn to be kinder
by the end, but the viewer has only learned
to distrust new takes on old favorites.
There was a sliver of time in the 2000s when
movies fell in love with surreal, motion-capture-powered
computer animation.
Robert Zemeckis, fresh from using this technique
in The Polar Express and Beowulf, decided
to apply it to A Christmas Carol.
Led by performances from Jim Carrey as Scrooge
and Gary Oldman as Bob Cratchit, the results
were...odd.
Some, like Roger Ebert, hailed it as "an exhilarating
visual experience."
Others, like The Telegraph, considered its
looks distracting, creating distance between
the characters and the audience that made
it difficult to connect to the story.
"There's more of gravy than of grave about
you, whatever you are."
"WAAAAH!"
Years later, the movie's reputation remains
mixed, and it's not hard to see why.
There are certainly strengths to be found.
Carrey's Scrooge is a bit goofier than other
renditions, but it fits the ghoulishly funny
tone of the movie, and Oldman's Cratchit is
pitch-perfect.
But the visuals, so dazzling in 2009, look
strange to modern eyes.
Plus, the tone of the film sits uncomfortably
between two extremes.
It's a little too dark to be heartwarming
and a bit too silly to be bleak.
Only one thing is truly clear: It's nobody's
go-to version when the holiday season rolls around.
You might not recognize Alan Menken by name,
but there's a good chance you know his work.
The Little Mermaid, Beauty and the Beast,
and Tangled all feature his songs.
So when he signed on to a brand new adaptation
of A Christmas Carol starring Kelsey Grammer,
hopes were high.
The man behind "A Whole New World" and "Under the Sea"
tackling one of the greatest holiday stories ever told?
That's not just a good idea — it's about as safe a bet as anyone gets in the entertainment industry.
And yet somehow, this version of Scrooge's
fateful transformation
leaves something to be desired.
The music is quite good, though it never hits
the highs of Menken's greatest work.
The story is solidly told, and the movie features
a fine performance from Jane Krakowski as
the Ghost of Christmas Past.
Grammer is as grumpy as Scrooge should be,
without ever crossing the line into total
awfulness.
And yet the entire affair is somehow inert.
It never stops feeling like something adapted
from the stage that probably should've stayed there.
On film, it never offends, but it doesn't
impress either.
It's trapped between worlds, unable to succeed
in either one.
Disney has been involved in multiple Christmas
Carol adaptations, but this is the one that
features the characters most central to the
brand.
Mickey, Minnie, and of course, Scrooge McDuck
all star in this particular take on the tale.
They bring a certain lightness to even the
darkest parts of the iconic story.
No one heads into A Christmas Carol thinking
Scrooge won't end up changing his ways, but
there's still something soothing about Mickey
Mouse leading the bleak first half of the story.
For the youngest viewers, this is an ideal
Carol indeed.
"Farewell, Ebenezer…"
Unfortunately, that's the only group this
version is meant for.
Anyone beyond the preschool years won't find
much to love about this take, blunted as it
is by Disney's core characters.
This isn't to say it isn't sweet to watch
beloved figures like Daisy Duck and Goofy
in London, learning the ways of goodwill toward
men.
The sheer number of A Christmas Carol adaptations,
though, means that no viewer has to settle
for mere sweetness.
Leave this version in the nursery where it
belongs, and move on to something better.
Unique among Carol adaptations, Scrooged actually
features an in-universe staging of the classic
Dickens tale.
Shrewd TV executive Frank Cross ordered it,
and he doesn't care how much strain it puts
on his overworked employees.
He is, of course, the Scrooge of this story.
"Oh my Gosh, does that suck."
He's even got an overworked assistant, a widow
named Grace, and an old flame whose work with
the homeless contrasts sharply with his greed.
Three ghosts visit him, lessons are learned,
and in the end, Frank, leads the Carol crew
in a rendition of the 1969 classic "Put a
Little Love in Your Heart."
Spins on Carol can go quite well, and this
one does, for the most part.
Modern mass media suits the protagonist, and
it's different enough from the original story
to be intriguing but similar enough to translate
smoothly.
Bill Murray in the title role plays Cross
with sharky, calculating menace.
He's a Scrooge the audience fears on a primal
level, as he's so destructive in a familiar way.
But there is a mean-spirited tone to the film,
as though the movie is embarrassed to seem
too earnest.
This pairs oddly with the sentimental ending,
which actually goes further down the road
to a happy ending than most Carols.
All in all, it's fun...but only just.
This isn't the only animated rendition of
A Christmas Carol on our list, but it might
just be the most visually striking, so much
so that it won an Oscar for Best Animated
Short Film.
Richard Williams, who masterminded Who Framed
Roger Rabbit?, directed and produced this
version, and the quality is clear in every
frame.
This version of A Christmas Carol is austere,
almost dour, thanks to the crew looking to
19th-century engravings for inspiration.
As a result, this version might not be the
one children respond to.
Plus, it's a short piece, only 25 minutes
long.
You can't help but wish the film had a little
more room to breathe, if only to explore the
possibilities of its unique animation more.
Still, the end result is a gorgeous half-hour
of pure Dickens, as warm-hearted as it is
deliberately rough around the edges.
You forget the happy ending within the grimy
first half of the tale, so it's all the more
delightful to rediscover that in the second.
Dickens' work isn't exactly what anyone would
describe as "feel good."
Sure, A Christmas Carol has a happy ending,
but the reader needs to earn it.
"Dickensian," after all, has become a descriptor
unto itself.
And this version of A Christmas Carol (aka
Scrooge) is truly Dickensian.
British giant of the stage and screen Alastair
Sim dons the stovepipe hat in this adaptation,
and he cranks up the grumpiness to memorable
levels.
It's a notably grim take on an already dark
tale, but it works, for the most part due
to Sim's unbeatable screen presence.
You hate Scrooge, but you never give up on
him.
That stirring central performance livens up
the whole production, making the film actively
entertaining, instead of simply faithful to
Dickens.
This is a deeply honest Christmas Carol, for
better and worse, but it never loses its faith
in humanity's ability to change.
A version of A Christmas Carol starring Patrick
Stewart already has a leg up on the competition.
Those who know his work will automatically
see him as a natural Scrooge, while those
who are new to his work will be quickly convinced.
His gruffness suits the character perfectly,
while his comedy chops come in handy towards
the end.
Stewart is an actor at the height of his powers
in this adaptation, as natural rolling his
eyes at orphans as he is embracing Tiny Tim.
He gives the entire production gravity, and
he loans every scene and set piece weight
and sophistication with his presence.
This take A Christmas Carol helps you understand
how Stewart's career has, if anything, only
grown with age.
The movie around him, in contrast, is merely
fine.
There's nothing to complain about, but beyond
Stewart's powerhouse performance, nothing
catches the eye.
That's easily forgiven thanks to Stewart,
but when placed beside other versions of the
story, it's a lot more noticeable.
Stewart is talented enough to make the production
notable, but in truth, he's the only thing
that does.
Happily for Dickens and Stewart fans alike,
A Christmas Carol is very much Ebenezer Scrooge's story.
Thus, this time, it's Patrick Stewart's story
as well.
"What the dickens have they done to Scrooge?"
the tagline of the Scrooge poster pleads.
It's also a musical, and one made in 1970
at that.
You hear these facts and imagine a sort of
perfect, anti-Dickens storm approaching.
And yet, Scrooge actually ends up being pretty
delightful.
Yes, it enjoys thumbing its nose at ideas
of the Victorian era and what a literary adaptation
should be.
But its heart is fixed firmly in the right
place, and that results in a truly wonderful
rendition of A Christmas Carol.
The songs serve the story rather than smothering
it, clarifying Dickens' themes as they spin
them into an entirely new medium.
Is this jauntier than the more classical takes
on the story?
Yes, but that's a virtue.
Scrooge might be making its own rules, but
it never loses sight of its source material.
There's no shortage of Christmas Carol adaptations
featuring top-class talent, especially in
the role of Scrooge.
But George C. Scott brings something unmatched
to this version, a sheer power that pours
from every frame.
An actor from West Virginia brings something
to a role as essentially British as Ebenezer
Scrooge that the actual Brits could do well
to learn from him.
This is a Scrooge who strides, and whose nastiness
stings all the more for the force he can put
behind it.
Thus, it's also a Scrooge who feels entirely
transformed by the final credits, and a Scrooge
who delivers the moral with renewed energy.
He isn't just changed by his ordeal with the
ghosts, but rebuilt as a new man with new
purpose.
Alongside a cast that brings a certain worn
quality many Carol adaptations lack, Scott
shines all the brighter.
It's not just a great take on a classic story,
or a collection of impressive performances.
It's a holiday treasure all its own.
Who'd have thought that a rendition of A Christmas
Carol starring Muppets would be one of the
best adaptations of all?
Unlike the worst offenders on this list, this
film doesn't just trot out the morals everyone expects.
It also doesn't put any unnecessary new spin
on things that don't need changing.
Rather, it highlights the best things about
the story while providing a new lens with
which to view them.
Thus, it helps us love them like we did the
very first time we heard the story.
To start with, there's Michael Caine's Scrooge.
He's as grouchy as he should be, but surrounding
him with puppets teases out a comical edge.
He's a terror, but you're laughing at him
from the beginning.
This makes the movie an ideal choice for the
youngest viewers, but it also gives the film
an inventive spin on Dickens' tale.
While some on this list succeed by leaning
into the story's darker elements, the Muppets
succeed by embracing the author's sense of
humor, joy, and goodwill.
Plus, you'll get to see Gonzo, best known
for his weird blue nose and love of chickens,
play cultural cornerstone Charles Dickens.
What's not to love?
What makes A Christmas Carol great?
There's the satisfaction of seeing a villain
confronted with the consequences of his actions.
There's the sly sense of humor that peeks
out from around the story's most cynical corners.
Plus, there's the community spirit that it
celebrates.
But beyond all of that, there's the hope it
kindles.
A Christmas Carol tells us that it's never
too late to be a bigger, better, and more
benevolent person.
"I shall change my way of living.
I will try to keep Christmas all the year."
It's this spirit that the 1938 adaptation
embodies.
From its first scenes to its sublime ending,
it's a beacon of progress in all its forms.
Reginald Owen's Scrooge is an old monster
who finds himself falling in love with life
again, flush with the fact that it isn't too
late for him.
That this film was made in the midst of the
Great Depression for a weary public remains clear.
This is a movie for those all too familiar
with Scrooge and his ilk, as Dickens' audience
was in its day.
This version of A Christmas Carol understands
the power of its story like few others, and
decades after its debut, it still shines like
it did the day of its premiere.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
Christmas movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.